hello my name is frank bergans and the
title of my talk is characterization and
scale translation of a parallel
microbioreactor system for psychiatrist
development
this work is part of an engineering
doctorate project between ucl
biochemical engineering
and aplicon biotechnology the aim of the
project
is to establish the micromatrix a
screening tool and scale down model for
cell culture applications
in this talk i will present the work on
the engineering characterization of the
micromatrix focusing on
mixing time and kla
then i will demonstrate how matched
mixing time
in combination with a similar co2
edition profile can be used to scale
down a fat bread process
using a gstr cell line producing an
igg4 antibody from a stair tank
benchtop scale reactor to the shaken
micro matrix system
subsequently the high throughput of the
microbio reactor will be used to perform
a doe assisted optimization of the
feeding strategy
lastly the optimize fat batch protocol
will be
translated to the benchtop scale
in a typical process development
timeline clone screening and selection
is usually done
in these 96 well plates
promising clones are then transferred to
shake flask where the medium composition
can be optimized
the process is then transferred to a
benchtop sphere
stair tank reactor where process
parameters such as
ph and dissolved oxygen can be actively
controlled
finally the translation to pilot
and production scale follows
both report and the amount of
information that can be obtained from a
run
are functions of the scale the smaller
the scale the more experiments can be
run in power layer but also less
information is obtained
at the larger scale financial and space
constraints
restrict the number of parallel
experiments
however these experiments allow for
better insight
at conditions closer to the actual
production process
microbio reactors like the micro matrix
shown here
try to shake up this inverse
relationship by offering a fully
controlled culture environment at small
scale that allows for a high degree of
parallelization
the micromatrix is designed around
a 24 deep square well microtiter plate
as shown here on the right you can see a
close-up
of one of the 24 welds each of the welds
has a filtered gas
inlet for the addition of up to four
gases
a gas outlet and a liquid line which
allows for feed addition
but also ph control on the bottom
of the well are sensors for the
measurement of phdo
and temperature
the microtiter plate sits inside the
micromatrix on an
inbuilt orbital shaker
and engineering characterization of the
micromatrix was conducted in order to
provide the basis for the scale down of
an
existing fat batch process
in a 5 liter stair tank reactor to the
micro matrix and the shaking
24 standard round valve format
this photo shows a setup of the mixing
time experiments
using a mock-up well of the same
dimension
as the micro matrix cassette welds
the well was fixed onto an orbital
shaker
the color change of a dual indicator
system for mixing time
solution was used to determine the
mixing time inside the well
under dynamic conditions pictures were
taken using a high-speed camera
mounted on the shaking platform shown
here
the mixing time was determined by
analyzing the pictures and visually
observing the color change
mixing time tests were performed for
different values of
volume and steering speed
the mixing time as
function of the rotational speed as
shown in the figure here was found to
range
between 1 and 42 seconds an
increased working volume generally led
to longer mixing times whereas increased
shaking speeds shorten
mixing times this
is an expected result and it also agrees
with previous studies where a similar
trend was demonstrated
as shown in this table for different
miniature bioreactor systems
this photo shows the setup to determine
the volumetric oxide atmospheric
coefficient
kla measurements were performed using
the static guessing out method
to perform the measurement with a high
frequency
and with a sufficiently short probe
response time
a needle type oxygen microsensor
was used as shown in this photograph
the probe was inserted through the
off-gas filter of the assembled
micromatrix cassette
all dissolved oxygen was first removed
from the liquid through overlay with
nitrogen
the headspace was then flushed
before the operating conditions with
regard to airflow rate and shaking speed
were set and recording commenced
the results are illustrated in these
figures where the kla is plotted as
function of shaking speeds for three
different
air flow rates
the values of the kla ranged
between 2 and 240 depending on the
operating conditions
used the mass transfer is directly
proportional to the surface area of the
liquid
with increasing shaking speeds the
liquid surface
gradually deformed and its inclination
grew
which led to larger liquid surface area
and therefore higher kla values
the kla had an inverse relationship to
the liquid volume and in turn decreased
with increasing
working volume however there was little
effect
of changing the airflow weight on the
kla
as you can see from these graphs
there are four different criteria that
are commonly used for scale translation
of their culture processes
the first is based on matched tip speed
however this is not applicable for
scaling between
shaken and steered systems the second is
based on matched power per unit volume
but this value can only be derived via
simulation
or elaborate experimental setup for
shaken
systems this leaves matched
kla or matched mixing time
as potential candidates for scale
translation between stair tank reactor
and the micromatrix
this table shows the operating
conditions
for the three different cultivation
system
used in this study a kla value
of one per hour is often cited as being
sufficient
to support cell densities of up to one
times ten to the seven
cells per milliliter and all cultivation
platforms fulfill
this requirement therefore a matched
mixing time of approximately 6 seconds
was chosen as criterion for the scale
translation from shaken microwave
systems to the benchtop scale
this figure shows the viable cell
concentration and viability of a
g-stroke cell grown
in the 5-liter stair tank reactor and
the micromatrix system
also the viability is very similar the
maximum viable cell concentration is
more than double
in the micro matrix compared to the five
liter
reactor in contrast
the igg4 antibody tita
is almost identical the results suggest
that similar mixing conditions alone do
not promote
similar cell growth closer inspection
of the carbon dioxide edition profile
showed large
differences between the stair tank
reactor
and the micro matrix this figure
shows the co2 is continuously
added via overlay in the micromatrix
due to the manual bolder's additions of
base by contrast in the five liter stair
tank reactor
co2 addition stopped after three days
due to lactate formation further
acidification is counteracted by base
addition when lactate is consumed
towards the end of the run
co2 addition started again as shown in
the graph
such as co2 edition profile was emulated
in the micro matrix by using the
automated feeding module
instead of manual bolus additions of
base
as you can see for both co2 it
conditions the growth and product
profiles
are comparable between the 5
litre stair tank reactor and the micro
matrix
furthermore the maximum
viable cell concentration did not show
significant differences for these
systems
also the growth of cells cultivated in
the
24 standard round wealth was slightly
slower the trend was comparable to the
cultivation that used
gas plants with five percent co2
similarly the maximum viable cell
concentration in the
24 standard round wells was reached at
the later stage of the cultivation
but was not significantly different
to either the micro matrix or five liter
stair tank reactor
in addition the final title was not
significantly different
between the scales and co2 conditions
this indicates a difference in the cell
specific
productivity caused by the difference
of the co2 concentrations in the
inflowing gas
this table shows a summary of the
results from the previous slide
confirming the impact of the co2 edition
profile and growth and product
formation in the micro matrix and 5
liter
stair tank bioreactor systems it also
shows a high degree of similarity
between the two controlled bioreactor
systems
for all derived parameters by contrast
some
larger differences in growth rate and
final tita
were found when cells were grown in the
24
standard round wealth system
in order to ascertain whether the n-link
glycosylation of the igg4
antibody was scalable the distribution
of key glycoprofiles was compared
as you can see here the percentage of
forecast related glycans
was above 95 percent at all scales
which was similar to earlier studies of
the same
cell line and product
the distribution of cyalated
antibodies was similar for the control
systems
but reduced further 24
standard round well format as you can
see in this graph
similarly galactosylation was
comparable for all conditions run in the
micromatrix and five liter stair tank
reactor
but considerably reduced for antibodies
that were produced
in the 24 standard round welds
this was likely caused by a difference
in the
ph profile because
cultures in the 24 standard round welds
were not ph controlled
in summary the results show that a match
mixing time in conjunction with a
similar
co2 edition profile proved to be a
suitable scaling criterium to translate
a fat batch process from a conventional
stair tank
bioreactor to the micromatrix system
demonstrated the scale translation of a
fat batch process we used the
micromatrix to optimize the bolus
feeding strategy
a design of experiment approach with a
circumscribed central composite design
was employed to investigate three
factors
these were the total feet volume and
percentage of the initial working volume
the feet start in days after inoculation
and feed weight in number of bolus
additions at the feed volume
was divided all were investigated
at five different levels the center
point was replicated six
times this resulted in 20 runs
in total performed in a single
experiment
the feeding regime was optimized for the
space time yield instead of the final
titer
in order to avoid a bias towards
long process run times
the contour plot here shows
the optimal space-time yield was
captured within the investigated design
space
the optimal value of 71 milligrams per
day and liter
was predicted for a feed start after
five days in the total feed volume
of 64 percent that was divided into six
bolus additions
the predicted optimal bolus feeding
regime was repeated in the micromatrix
for validation
and then scaled up to the benchtop
bioreactor
the comparison to the original fat batch
protocol
shown as historic in grey was
made to assess the success of the
optimization
the results show minimal differences of
the growth kinetics between the scales
for the optimized feeding regime
in comparison to the original feeding
strategy
the moderate increase of the maximum
viable cell concentration and the
prolonged stationary
phase were observed
similarly the progression of the tita
was nearly identical between the scales
for the optimized feeding regime
and significantly higher compared
to the original fat batch regime as
shown
in this graph
these results are confirmed by the
comparison of the derived parameters
that were almost identical between the
micro matrix and the 5 liter stair tank
reactor under optimized
conditions whereas the values
for the original feeding regime showed a
substantially reduced
productivity as shown in this table
the final title and space-time yield of
the
optimized feeding protocol was about
20 percent higher compared to the
original protocol
and very close to the predicted optimum
in conclusion initially
an engineering characterization
of mixing time and kla was performed to
gain
an understanding of the cultivation
environment generated by the system
mixing and kla were found to be
comparable to other
microbioreactor systems and lab scale
bioreactors
based on the information obtained from
the engineering characterization
the mixing time was selected to remain
constant between
the 5 liter sdr micromatrix
and 24 stand around well to ensure
comparable
hydrodynamic conditions furthermore the
growth kinetics of the used cell lines
were highly dependent
on the co2 addition profile
as a result the concentration of co2 in
the inflow and gas
was also matched between the shaken
micro matrix and the five liters their
tank reactor
leading to very similar growth in
product kinetics
as well as glycosylation profiles for
both
co2 conditions
the high throughput of the micromatrix
was then leveraged to optimize the bolus
feeding strategy within the framework
of a circumscribed central composite
design
a scale up of the optimized feeding
regime demonstrated nearly identical
growth and production kinetics
between the micrometrics and the
benchtop scale
reactor and resulted in a 20 increase of
the space-time yield compared to the
original
feeding regime the results demonstrate
the potential of the micromatrix system
a scaled-down model
for fat batch cell culture processes and
its application for
process optimization
all the work presented was carried out
by vincent weakman
with support of dr gregorio
rodriguez and miss e lee in setting up
the mixing time experiments
i would also like to thank aplicon
biotechnology for
provision of the micromatrix system
and financial support of the nhd
studentship i would like to thank ludga
limited for their help with the
glycosylation analysis in lonza uk
for provision of the gs show cell line
this work was supported by the uk
engineering and physical science
research council as part of an
engineering doctorate training center
grant
in bioprocess engineering leadership
finally thank you for listening to my
presentation
and i'm happy to answer any of your
questions